Soon you'll be able to earn virtual currency
in virtual reality.
If you take the number of hours that you spend
looking at a screen, a good chunk of that,
maybe all of that, gets replaced with a VR
helmet.
Which means that, for a good chunk of people
in the world, the majority of their waking hours
are going to be spent in the Matrix.
The Silicon Valley entrepreneur Balaji Srinivasan
is a modern-day polymath who venture capitalist
Marc Andreessen has called the person with
“the highest output per minute of new ideas
of anybody I’ve ever met in my life.”
A Ph.D. in electrical engineering, a co-founder
of a genetic testing firm,
and a Stanford computer science lecturer, Srinivasan was
also on Donald Trump’s
short list to head up the Food and Drug Administration.
Today, he spends most of his time as CEO of
the cryptocurrency startup, Earn.com.
Srinivasan believes in the power of technology
to provide a way for individuals
to migrate away from ossified institutions or destructive
policies.
Borrowing from the classic book by Albert O. Hirschman,
he refers to this path as "exit."